In the US, Acting Secretary of Defense Pat Shanahan...
...said steps taken to bolster the US military presence in the Middle East...
...have deterred Iran and "put on hold the potential for attacks on Americans,"...
...even as Iran carried out other attacks.
In New Zealand, authorities are filing terrorism charges against the self-avowed white supremacist...
...who killed 51 worshippers at two Christchurch mosques in March.
In Malawi, President Peter Mutharika is seeking a second term,...
...as voters in the southern African nation cast ballots in Tuesday's general election.
In Indonesia, President Joko Widodo is officially declared...
...the winner of last month's presidential election...
...that international observers say was free and fair.
Finally in Britain, Prime Minister Theresa May...
...set out to secure a "new deal" for Britain's departure from the European Union,...
...offering sweeteners to opposition parties...
...in her fourth attempt to break an impasse in parliament over Brexit.